after world war ii they began to think
of combat
is also a production process
the officer corps were seen not as
gladiator heroes who were leading men in
combat but as war managers
in turn the enlisted men
were no longer the citizens of a nation
but they were workers
managers and workers worked on a
production line to produce deaths
and the product then was enemy body
counts an american perspective if the
only thing that counts in warfare is
technology and economics both in your
economy and how you translate your
economy into your military
then week it was impossible for us to
lose
and in fact in some units
kind of where the informal rule was if
you don't meet your body count quota
then we're going to like you're not
coming in off the field
there are stories of where people from
different units had to fight over arms
and legs to determine who was going to
get the kill count
for their unit
search and destroy reached the point
where if any say you many units burn
down villages routinely
and then you go in a village and you
burn it and
and
you see their bunkers there because all
everyone in vietnam had a bunker to hide
in and you hear a noise and maybe you
maybe you scream and try to get somebody
out but maybe you just throw the grenade
in
or people start to run away from you
and well if they run from you they must
be your enemy
and so you shoot them and you say well
running becomes a sign of an enemy
what's in practice is this the mere
group rule if it's dead it's vietnamese
it's vc any vietnamese we shoot we're
going to count
we take a fresh new look at the vietnam
war
from the highest levels of the generals
in the planners
to the perspective of the
lowly enlisted man
on the ground
you will never view the vietnam war in
the same way you did in the past after
spending this hour with us and the
author of the new book the perfect war
tonight on alternative views
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sighting down the long barrel
i wait
till front and rear sights form a
perfect line on his body
and then
slowly squeeze the trigger
the thought occurs that i have never
hunted anything in my whole life
except
other men
vietnam america's longest war its most
costly war its first military detroit
feat and its most nightmarish national
trauma people are still asking what went
wrong how and why did the u.s get
involved was vietnam a tragic mistake as
liberals claimed did the u.s lose
because of self-imposed constraints as
conservatives claim could we have won
the war if we just unleashed the
military machine and bombed the north
vietnamese back to the stone age what
was the cost of vietnam the human cost
the political costs the economic costs
to both the united states and the
vietnamese
one person who has been researching
these questions for over 10 years is
william gibson who has just published a
book the perfect war techno war in
vietnam with atlantic monthly press
bill is a graduate of the university of
texas where he did his undergraduate
work and he got his phd at yale
university and is now a professor of
sociology at southern methodist
university in dallas and we're very
pleased to have you with us today on
alternative views bill to discuss your
vietnam book this is an incredible book
bill
if you have
read a lot about vietnam or if you have
never read anything about vietnam
this is the one you should read
because it
shows
the picture from the top from the bottom
and it gives an explanation as to what
really happened there and why things
happen
usually you come back with kind of an
empty feeling of frustration or not
really
knowing but you after reading your book
you understand which is incredible
incredible thank you and you got the
emotional feeling the impact as well as
what was happening in the mines and
these incredible stories like how
the north vietnamese were able to bring
down american jets just by lying on
their back and firing 45s and rifles up
into the sky but i'm getting ahead of
the story yes bill let's begin by
talking about what in your opinion is
distinctive about the vietnam war what
brought about u.s involvement in this
ill-fated adventure
the most distinctive feature of the
vietnam war
is that it was the first war in modern
times
to be fought
from a managerial business perspective
during world war ii u.s industry made a
massive contribution to the war effort
and american military men and political
leaders fully appreciated that effort
during world war ii the military
partially adopted a business model of
organization for their supply operation
after world war ii they began to think
of combat
is also a production process
the officer corps were seen not as
gladiator heroes who were leading men in
combat but as war managers
in turn the enlisted men
were no longer the citizens of a nation
but they were workers
managers and workers worked on a
production line to produce deaths
and the product then was enemy body
counts
so just as american society's strength
supposedly was high technology capital
intensive business
so too would we fight wars
as high technology capital intensive
warfare we would literally drive the
other side bankrupt so it's this
production model of war or what i call
techno war that distinguishes
at a primary structural level vietnam
from other warfare
so then in this way we couldn't lose
because we were fighting a small
underdeveloped untechnical third world
country with peasants basically
exactly from an american perspective if
the only thing that counts in warfare is
technology and economics both in your
economy and how you translate your
economy into your military
then we was impossible for us to lose it
was theoretically impossible for an
underdeveloped peasant economy to beat
the united states it just couldn't
happen
therefore
whenever we ran into a problem
in 454 or 60 or 64 at every time the u.s
was defeated
we always thought that if we escalated
to the next highest level we would win
it's a closed system
and bill why was vietnam chosen as the
site for the first techno war
there's no historical reason for vietnam
in other words really vietnam as a
country as a people as a culture didn't
really matter to the americans
so there was nothing about
about the country per se
to make us fight there it was simply the
time when this whole apparatus of
warfare was developing
vis-a-vis the time when
situation in vietnam was deteriorating
from an american perspective
techno war or
this this production model of war got
its big push in the 50s
because after world war ii when we had
the hydrogen bomb or the atomic bomb and
then later the hydrogen bomb and the
russians didn't
it seemed clear to us that our mastery
of the world was just unsurpassed and we
could not be challenged
but when the russians had the bomb we
were in a situation of potentially
mutual destruction where they could
destroy our industrial apparatus
then this made the americans feel
impotent
and so the question came is how can we
develop a form of warfare
to
exercise our power in the world without
threatening
nuclear war and the idea developed by dr
henry kissinger
who at the time was a professor at
political science at harvard was what's
called limited war
and the idea was because our economy was
so big and powerful
we could have guns and butter butter and
tvs and popcorn and drive-ins for hula
hoops for the americans at home
and
limited war
for an indefinite period of time in the
third world and because we were so much
richer we would just drive the other
side bankrupt and it was a period where
certain guerrilla movements certain
national liberation movements were
emerging we saw the cuban revolution in
1959 and there were third world
revolutionary movements throughout the
western africa the french and british
empires were deteriorating worldwide
certainly in vietnam was a classic case
that vietnam had been a french colony
that went through a long process of
revolt so vietnam was simply it was
ready we had our theory for limited war
and we had our apparatus in place at the
time vietnam was
well by the time the french had been
thrown out
can you give us a brief history of
vietnam and their struggle first against
the chinese and the french etc leading
up to american intervention
certainly the word vietnam originally it
means southern kingdom of viet
and it was a
part of china that
well i didn't really break off it's like
chinese immigrated there and they formed
and formed a racially distinct group
and tried to decline claim independence
chinese emperors would invade vietnam
hold the country for several hundred
years vietnamese guerilla fighters would
throw the chinese out the chinese would
then invade and hold it for another
fifty hundred years then the vietnamese
would throw him out
and hold on for fifty years this the
struggle between vietnam and china for
vietnamese independence went on for
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of years
finally by the time the vietnamese had
finally defeated china
they were in pride they were weak though
and this is the time when the west was
expanding and france was looking for a
way to get to china for the spice trade
and so on and they ended up taking
vietnam
so france took
vietnam as a colony in the 1890s
vietnamese fought off and on against the
french from the 1890s on up
oh they just kept on fighting but then
in world war ii
the communist
especially headed by ho chi minh and
beau new york [ __ ] and laid up toe
organized better
they fought against the japanese
and then after declared their
independence in 45 and ironically
american
intelligence operatives supported that
effort extensively
and ho chi minh as i understand it
looked at that time to the united states
as a model to develop his country not to
the soviet his position was that he had
paid off whatever he felt he
ideologically owed to the soviet union
and that he was a free agent he was not
getting any assistance and that the
america with the declaration of
independence and with its stated
anti-imperialist policy was a far better
possible ally and it was a model of
democracy for him too and at that time
he was a nationalist and a democrat to
some extent
certainly a nationalist how much of a
democrat i'm not i i wouldn't
he was pretty much paid service to the
democratic values and the
anti-imperialists but certainly in
nationals well then the vietnamese
defeated the french and 54 after eight
years of extensive warfare extensive
guerilla warfare it's important for us
to understand
the war in vietnam was one country it
had been tentatively divided into three
administrative zones by the french but
warfare was going on on all three when
the war ended in 54 the country looked
like a checkerboard
some french in the north some vietnamese
or yet men in the north some french
cities held in the south other areas
held by the
by the vietnamese communist
north and south vietnam didn't exist it
was only a checkerboard
but then at the geneva peace talks in
1954 there was a land
swap vietnamese forces moved north
french consolidated their forces in the
south
a line was drawn a provisional
administrative boundary not a national
boundary not a political boundary it
administrated its own boundary the idea
was the country would be divided for two
years and there would be international
elections in 56. there were no such
elections the united states moved in
what's important to understand this idea
of north vietnam is a separate country
that invaded south vietnam is wrong
there was no north and south vietnam as
two separate countries that was a
uh just a it was a checkerboard at the
end of 54 that got they got changed and
what happened in the south to begin the
resistance struggle
when
the grill when in 54
the vietcong and the south
were told to put down their guns and
that they were going to engage in
political struggle
for two years in preparation for the 56
elections
that became extremely dangerous
dim the man the americans put in power
immediately went after and hunted down
most of the communist leftists democrats
nationalist noise jim and his family
rule vietnam pretty much as a
dictatorship
and finally by by the late 50s
the local
communist and guerrilla and socialist
and democratic apparatus was taking
casualties so badly
that they had to renew the armed
struggle to survive and so simply then
the southern cadres put pressure on the
north on the communist party to like
reopen the military front and have a
joint politically military strategy as
opposed to simply trying to wait for
international uh intervention or by the
united nations or something
so that that's the origin of resistance
and what was the us response to this
then
the response was quite simple this is uh
when the green berets who had originally
been formed to parachute into eastern
europe
after
to organize guerrilla movements in
eastern europe got reformulated
as counter insurgency experts and they
were sent to vietnam by president
kennedy in 1960 it was also a massive
increase in cia operations the whole
idea of covert warfare remember an
encounter insurgency warfare remember we
had failed at the bay of pigs in 1961
and so the idea was we must become
experts at fighting these uh wars of
national liberation and that we must
have new warrior technicians who could
intervene in underdeveloped country
countries
and
fix things and the green berets
were one branches fix it men cia
operatives were another various
logistics people econ economists
were others
we should remember
let's understand the class structure of
vietnam it's a poor rural society
most of the people are landless peasants
our own very small plots of land they're
under subsistence agriculture where a
large part of their crop goes to the
landlord
a small land owning club most pea
peasants are buddhist with practice
elements of confucianism as well
a small land owning class a lot many of
them refugees from the north
many of them catholic controls the
nation's wealth
so
diem and
the government diem uses in the army as
a mechanism to collect rents
and during the first war against the
french the vietcong had redistributed
the land to the peasantry
so when dim came to power in 54 with the
army and acted as agents of the landlord
to collect years of back rent
essentially the internal class
polarization increased one more time
and drove people to the vietcong into
revolutionary perspective exactly and
then zm had to use more and more
repression
as a result of the dissatisfaction of
the and the repression in turn meant
that in essence that the kind that the
vietcong or communist forces felt like
they had to resort to armed struggle
again so this is why you made your
statement in your book that zam had an
army but he didn't have he was not a
government
that's right no there was no effective
administration other than military
administration dim eventually replaced
all forms of village council all forms
of intermediary powers that that had any
linkage to to below were destroyed
instead all loyalty was from the top
down
yet the american escalation didn't
really dramatically accelerate until
after dm's assassination what brought
about this dramatic
acceleration and what you call techno
war to vietnam with dam was gone all the
other vietnamese generals began a power
struggle among themselves
consequently whatever government
repressive apparatus dim had collapsed
desertions increased radically
defections to vietcong units became
stronger and stronger
by 64 american policymakers feared that
there would be a provisional
revolutionary government might an open
provisional revolutionary government in
much of the countryside which we had
lost
remember state u.s forces lost our the
french lost in 45
we lost again in 54 we lost again in 63
64. we escalate their united states
escalates in the face of defeat not in
the face of victory right
so
massive defeat in 63 and 64 brought
again then the need for u.s ground
troops and sustained bombing of the
north in order to try to salvage the
situation why couldn't the u.s accept a
defeat in this small corner of the world
the united states has been unwilling to
deal with communism as a political
social and economic movement instead it
gets seen that we as americans are the
natural beings of the world and
capitalism is the natural economic order
and that our system is simply
the essence of human goodness and the
essence of nature therefore something
very very different from us is not
another society with whom one compares
differences and makes treaties with and
so on and so forth but instead
is an alien presence if we're nature
they're anti-nature or what i call the
foreign other
during world war ii
the soviet union
did take over right after world war ii
did invade and take over eastern europe
the red army did and you had to hold it
as a buffer zone and they did install
puppet
dictatorships there
this became the model
for
all american views of communist and
socialist of any kind
americans did not understand internal
revolution they did not understand the
chinese revolution in the 40s that there
were like millions upon millions of poor
peasants who wanted land to survive and
that mao seitong and the communist party
offered them land and survival whereas
chiang kai-shek was a warlord who
offered them nothing
so
unable to see internal struggles for
socialism or communism or
unable to see even internal struggles
for national independence against
colonialism the world gets divided into
them and us
and we're the good guys and they're the
bad guys they are the foreign other
they're trying to move in so all forms
of communism get movements get seen in
that light so in this sense then any
particular movement in the world it's
not just a particular movement in a dirt
poor country let's remember how dirt
poor vietnam is then
and we had very little investment there
instead any movement is a sign of the
global movement
a few poor peasants win in vietnam
that doesn't mean just that they have
that a little few more people have a few
more rice instead that means that the
foreign other the monolithic machine has
encroached one more step and that with
each other step
the rest of the world becomes imperil
this of course the domino theory so like
a contagious disease sort of instead of
like each country having its own history
and its own culture and its own people
it's as if
the world is an empty shell
like a chessboard and see the our side
of their side and you
once they get going just somehow a
mechanistic momentum will propel
communism to victory
it's a very i call it mechanistic
anti-communism because it's a
mechanistic framework of the world and
the enemy is
is foreign real enemy at all it's an
abstraction so isn't that also aren't
there two sides of this the other side
is the people the big decision makers
the foreign policy establishment as you
term it
looking at the world on a more realistic
basis
as
general maxwell taylor said in his book
we have to
keep an iron grip on the third world
country because they are poor and they
want riches and the riches would have to
come from us
so they look at any type of victory such
unique as an econ such as in vietnam
as
providing an example to other third
world countries that if they can do it
and get away with it in vietnam they can
get away with it
it's a universal sign the victory in
vietnam is a universal sign of
national liberation victory everywhere a
defeat in vietnam means that
all liberation movements will give up
their struggles so bill given the fact
of this military industrial complex in
the united states that had built up a
new military machine and model of
warfare given the mechanistic
anti-communism that was motivating the
foreign policy decisions of the u.s
foreign policy establishment and given
the collapse of the dm south vietnamese
government in vietnam it was almost
inevitable that u.s involvement would
intensify that this war was not an
accident that this war was not just a
policy mistake but it was a consequence
basically of u.s foreign policy and u.s
industrial and military
development since world war ii that this
was the test case this is where they had
to test their war machine and stop
communism i really want to stress
together that i am
one of the principal
arguments i'm trying to like critique in
my book is this notion that we just made
one mistake after another that nobody
was really responsible for anything that
things just sort of slipped up
you don't go to war that way you go to
war far far in advance
in 64 when johnson was making
announcements about the gulf of town ken
and just sort of like how it was a
surprise attack which
it wasn't
and in early 65
when they were making announcements to
the american public that maybe we'd send
a few thousand more troops to vietnam
they fully expected to send two hundred
thousand people by the end of sixty-five
they another hundred and sixty two
hundred thousand by sixty-six and
another hundred thousand by sixty-seven
was the estimates were already there
that'd be a take a half million men
it was a planned out war this was a
planned warfare a planned escalation
well let's talk about the war itself and
see how this techno war actually worked
out itself in the ground and in the air
the use of helicopters the helicopter
war and the search and destroy can you
describe these and how they worked in
that
well let me quote a very famous general
julian yule
generals write books
they're kind of like academicians they
need to like write to publish in order
to get further promoted at the hierarchy
we normally don't believe that but i
think that way but it's it's true and to
justify their actions and judges to
justify their actions
all right yule's book is called
sharpening the combat edge the use of
analysis to reinforce military justice
military judgment it's published by
department of the army
and in the first chapter
yule says that we could compare search
and destroy operations in vietnam to an
assembly line
wow
that it was a you know a literally a war
factory that the objective was like
unlike a world war ii of world war one
when you have a continuous front going
on thousands of miles and you have major
offensives and then a counter offensive
and then a law
in vietnam it's a factory you turn the
factory on you let it run full blast all
the time and that's the managerial
problem how do you just allocate your
resources given the fact that you've
already decided to run at maximum
capability to produce body to produce
body counts
search and destroy means that
somewhere between several hundred and
several thousand american soldiers
are going to search
a block of countryside for vietcong
or north vietnamese troops
and they're going to try to engage them
in combat and of course and destroy
whatever troops or where whatever
supplies they capture
in theory it's strategic offensive
meaning it's a way to put the vietcong
make them
weaker put them on them to hunt them
down
it's as if
we're hunters and they're the prey
the objective
is to kill the enemy so fast that we
reach what's called recall the crossover
point this is general william
westmoreland's term the crossover point
means you're killing the enemy faster
than they can replace their casualties
it's like you're going to drive the
other side bankrupt
right so with all of our high technology
with our helicopters our jet fighter
bombers our tanks
we'll put just
grind them up
now that's the theory
the practice of search and destroy often
turned out very differently
in that part of simply
of a factory means a set of routine
and these routines were quite visible to
the vietnamese
for example we just didn't all of a
sudden show up unannounced into an area
and begin the search
instead
you had to like reconnaissance planes
had to go over it
artillery guns had to shoot smoke rounds
into the jungle into the landing zone so
that all the other artillery guns could
sight in so they could like fire
protective artillery strikes around the
landing zone
if you're any kind of vietcong commander
if you see a smoke round coming up in
the jungle while you know that the
americans are getting ready to launch a
helicopter assault
there aren't that many clear zones that
clear areas in mountainous territory or
in swamps or in
in jungle you can tell where the landing
zones are
so many times the vietcong commanders
had a very
substantial advance notice upon when the
americans were going to begin an
operation
consequently they had the choice do we
run and hide or do we ambush
the americans then land
the second first wave takes the landing
zone the second and third waves bring in
more artillery
if you're a vietcong commander you get
out your compass and your map
you draw a circle a radius on their map
and that will tell you because you know
that american artillery 105 millimeter
howitzer has a 10 000 meter radius
so you know that the americans will not
march further outside the range of their
howitzers so you can tell
where the americans are going to march
do you run and hide or do you fight
so the same kind of principle goes on
it's it's in essence they knew where we
were but we did not know where they were
and they had the they had the initiative
they then had the initiative it's their
terrain it's their terrain
so it has even by the military's own
statistics
roughly three quarters of the battles in
vietnam were initiated by the vietcong
and nba meaning they ambushed u.s forces
and could make a decision also
most battles ended when the vietcong and
nba wanted them ended
they could like initiate conduct and
break contact and that's those are two
crucial definitions of combat initiative
and your other statistic that only in
two percent of the search and destroy
missions did we actually make contact uh
original contact with the vietnamese so
it was their choice the whole time and
as i understand the soldiers themselves
on the ground they didn't like this
because they were the ones who would
have to take the casualties first
to lure the vietnamese into battle
so that then the americans would know
where to send the planes and where to
send their artillery
you send out a patrol in order to get it
ambushed in order to mark a target with
a smoke rocket from a helicopter or so
that then the jets can come in and they
palm the area in other words you have to
get ambushed before you can find the
enemy
you know when i began my vietnam
research i had a hint that i was going
to find a very cavalier attitude towards
whether or not the vietnamese lived or
died
i was surprised to understand the
command's attitude towards their own
soldiers
but let's think about it we're talking
about a production model of war again or
techno war this is the u.s war manager
these are the u.s war managers we have a
draft we can replace all the cat all the
labor
that we lose can be replaced and indeed
it's like migrant labor force we're
almost sort of like say we had a farm
when you bring them in for a year and a
year
blacks and chicanos anyway
quite a well not most but a whole lot of
them are they're poor working-class
whites
the idea was
so what if they walk into an ambush we
take some casualties that way but then
we'll call in our airstrikes and call in
our artillery fire and we use our
technology then to to get the body count
so in essence
the ground troops were bait
they were being sent out
on operations to be ambushed
and that's not a good way to survive
in warfare
night movement
that was suicide
that was one of the worst patrols you
could ever go out
on the purpose of it was for you to walk
up on charlie and
for him to hit you
and then for our hardware to wipe them
out
we were using scapegoats to find out
where they were
that was all we were
bait
hell they couldn't find charlie any
other way
so they loved us to run into a whole
bunch of them that way they could
plaster him and they'd have a big body
count then the general gets another
goddamn medal and a big promotion
let's also note again
the highest officer routinely on the
ground during vietnam was a captain a
captain was a company commander a
company had at most about 140 people in
it that would be at full strength
most combat units never operated full
strength
everyone above captain's level a
battalion commander is the man who
commands four companies
all battalion level officers brigades
brigades command several battalions
divisions have several regiments or
brigades all the rest of those choppers
all the rest of those commanders are in
helicopters
flying at minimum at fifteen hundred
feet because fifteen hundred feet is the
maximum range of a fifty caliber machine
gun when used as an anti-aircraft weapon
which until the latter part of the war
was the largest anti-aircraft weapon the
viet cong had
so the managers were relatively safe
in this process whereas the workers who
are suffering the occupational safety
hazards real hazards on on the ground
was it a success in terms of the numbers
and the body counts did they actually in
their own inhuman logic succeed or were
the costs greater than the benefits even
in terms of their own logic
several
things happened
for one
all the american commanders and
helicopters communicated in uncoded
english
to their subordinate officers and ground
troops
the vietcong and nva
were able to buy
american radios in the black market and
capture others they routinely listened
in into all the orders there are many
stories
of people of viet cong hearing american
orders and then taking actions to
circumvent them
so
the sheer arrogance of
you know wearing my helicopters we have
all this stuff we don't have to care we
don't have to pay attention to our enemy
it ended up costing american lives
so that part
didn't work
it took
within a year or so by late 66 or so
the economic nba knew how long it was
going to take an american airstrike to
get there
sometimes they could make a terrible
miscalculation and get caught out in the
open
but an astute enemy commander
could
make a reasonable judgment on how long
he could stay in combat before he had to
run like hell because the
f4s or the or the hueys or the gunships
were coming after him
so a lot of times
ambushes would be quite brief and the
enemy would break off contact
well we've mentioned body count a couple
of times let's get into that and the
whole framework of corruption and lies
and cover-ups that occur it's very
it's simple
we followed so far
if the success in war is purely an enemy
body count that's because we're trying
to drive the other side bankrupt and
let's presume that
oh you and doug are
i'm a general and that like your
lieutenants are captains right maybe
your captain come out company commander
somewhere
you're under pressure i'm under pressure
to produce a body count and it's a
colonel say i'm a criminal battalion
commander if i don't meet my quota
my career is over with i'll be relieved
of command and if you're relieved of
combat command then your your ticket up
the hierarchy
is is gone
so i'm going to squeeze you
and in fact in some units
kind of where the informal rule was if
you don't meet your body count quota
then we're going to like you're not
coming in off the field we'll just leave
you i'll bring you some more ammo some
more food some more water but don't
expect you know you've got to like
produce the goods
i knew if i came back without a body
count or at least a prisoner
and
get my ass chewed
so i kept the patrol out
well i talked to
many soldiers who were wounded the ones
i saw in japan
and they told me that some units were
given a quota for the week
and if they didn't get it
they were just sent right back out again
all right you're under pressure you're
under severe severe pressure
so what do you do
well you can do several things
one you can just invent a body count you
can just out of the thin air and just
like
say call up and have a like tell
everyone in your unit
kevin tell your entire class there at ut
to fire off their m16 for about for a
minute called a mad minute
and uh call up on the radio and report
that i have a you have a body count of
30. our body count of 5 or something
like that
or say you get ambushed frank and your
whole company gets ambushed
and you call it an airstrike and you
call in an artillery strike and there's
an armored unit nearby
and you actually have an engagement and
you find some enemy bodies well how do
you then
what are you going to do
well
[Music]
if you found 10 bodies and you've got
three different units
artillery air and infantry involved
who's going to get the credit
what if you don't give credit to the
artillery
what do you think might happen then what
if you say you fired but you missed
does that sound like a wise policy to
you their artillery commander isn't
going to give you any support you might
be kind of slow next time around or
those f4 pilots might have to have uh
they might get a little slow too it's in
your interest to reward everyone and
since everyone is under the same system
everyone needs body counts why sure
we give you 50 air force we give you 50
gunships we give you 50 artillery and we
on the ground
well
i've got five bodies and i've got five
rifles we'll count each rifle as the
five persons killed so that gives us 25
and while we were out stumbling around
we found 10 enemy grenades
tom beg your pardon ten graves we'll
count them too
um
and body parts and body parts say we
find an arm or a leg and say because
sometimes really when the air strikes
did hit you can't blow people to
smithereens unlike the war movie where
everyone has a nice discreet death
in a real war
it's quite gruesome
there are stories of where people from
different units had to fight over arms
and legs
to determine who was going to get the
kill count
for their unit
and of course it got the got even more
pernicious because
they would slaughter vietnamese
civilians and include them i mean
children women old people include them
as part of the body count as well we
should get clear on on that about
in some areas of the war where u.s
forces were fighting uniformed north
vietnamese troops
there weren't too many civilian
casualties
a whole whole lot of vietnam battles
occurred way inside the country
where there were vietcong and vietcong
and the villagers were were very much
the same people
well now on search and destroy missions
they told us to kill everything that
moves
so we killed everybody
i just happened to be standing alongside
the officer
when the radio man said look sir we've
got some children rounded up what do you
want us to do with them
and the officer says god damn it marine
you know what to do with them kill the
bastards if you ain't got the goddamn
balls to kill a marine i'll come down
and kill the bastards myself
the marine said yes sir
and hung up the phone
and about two or three minutes later i
heard a lot of automatic fire
and a lot of
children screaming
i heard babies crying
i heard children
screaming their lungs out
search and destroy reached the point
where if any say you many units burn
down villages routinely
and then you go in a village and you
burn it and
and
you see their bunkers there because all
everyone in vietnam had a bunker to hide
in and you hear a noise and maybe you
maybe you scream and try to get somebody
out but maybe you just throw the grenade
in
or people start to run away from you
and well if they run from you they must
be your enemy
and so you shoot them and say so running
becomes a sign of an enemy
well we'd been out for about three hours
and really hadn't seen anything it was
too hot but then i saw this figure in
black pajamas running along a paddy dyke
about 300 meters ahead and to the left
oh hey i got one i hollered 10 o'clock
he's mine
then i muttered the warning to halt you
know regulations
dun lai don't lie
so i dropped one knee
squeeze the trigger
crack
figure in black went flying like a piece
of paper and a gust of wind oh
got some morgan shouted nice shot baby
nice shot said nukem
when he reached the body i nudged the
corpse face up with my boot
there's a woman
about 55-60
and wally says
stupid [ __ ]
what'd she run for
we were
in a free fire zone
and we saw women and a woman a child
running across and the captain says well
they're there they're running
well in the free fire zone if they're
running they're wrong they're the enemy
so we shot him the whole squad opened up
on him
the next morning we went out and we
could see the cap of a child that was
bloodied
and you could see where the mother had
dragged the child away
troops are under they're afraid they're
trying to survive they're in a desperate
situation they're under high pressure to
produce a body count
so yes we got into sustained slaughter
of vietnamese villagers
you go through and you look at a man's
hands
and
if he's a true farmer he has calluses
and if he's a gorilla
who's only a fake farmer he doesn't so
you go and you look at the hands and
those if he doesn't have enough
callouses and you haul him away you send
him to an interrogation center
or you look at the ankles
if
a man is a gorilla he must be running
out there in the jungle getting his
ankles all scratched up where if he's a
farmer he wouldn't have so many
scratches so people would go american
soldiers would go around and look at the
ankles
or if he's a gorilla if you actually
mean a farmer by day and a fighter by
night you must not be getting much sleep
so you've got to have circles under your
eyes so u.s soldiers would go in and
look into the eyes
of the vietnamese and try to decide how
many how many bags they had and then you
have too many bags you get you get
hauled off
we it was not our country it was not our
culture we did not speak the language
and by the american way of looking at
war
language culture history class structure
these matters didn't didn't matter what
matters we had the hardware and they
didn't
well as the pilot of a helicopter
gunship we had a rule
about the use of evasive action anyone
taking evasive action could be fired
upon
they never explained why
or even what it was but anyway there was
one incident i recall where we flew over
a large rice patty and there were some
people down there working in the rice
paddy maybe a dozen or 15 individuals
and we passed over their heads
well they didn't take any action but we
could tell they were nervous
but they didn't try to hide or anything
so we hovered just a few feet off the
ground among them with our two
helicopters we turned on our police
sirens and boy when they heard the
police sirens they started to disperse
and so we opened up on them just shot
them all down
well 6 30 in the evening
and still daylight and they said there
was some vc out there and they called on
us
so we fired out there and killed off
seven of them
well the word comes back to us we killed
seven rice farmers carrying their hoes
they're trying to make it back to the
village
you see we'd set up this uh curfew 6 p.m
to 6 a.m
and so it was up to them to be out of
there by that time but hell they didn't
carry any wrist watches they didn't have
any idea what time it was
so yes people got hauled away for
interrogation and never came back
yes many many villages were burned to
the ground
and blown up
and yes
many many many many vietnamese
men women children
chickens water buffalo
pigs piglets
often were killed oftentimes you went
into a village the stores are you shot
everything and burned the crops and
burned the crops
boy you know if the people don't treat
you right when you walk through that
village you can give them hail
yeah they give you that snotty look they
can do you they won't say nothing to you
and we expecting them to run out and
welcome us like that world war ii type
of stuff you know hey hey gi hey
well
as soon as we step outside the village
the captain radio's in
we're under heavy contact then right
away oh those phantom jets start coming
in and dropping them 500 pound bombs the
whole village is leveled
and we go on to the next village
and that is search and destroy
all this was i guess part of what you
call the mayor [ __ ] rule
yes essentially
if it's dead as vietnamese as vc
you know
what it is armies have documents called
rules of engagements that are supposed
to specify when you can open up fire
when you can't on civilians
but
they weren't used much at all
instead other kind of rules happen like
i said if they run they're an enemy or
if they have black pajamas that was one
rule some units thought that any
vietnamese wearing black
uh garb was the enemy of course all
peasants
that wore that as their national dress
um
so there in all kinds of these fake
rules that supposedly distinguish been
friend from foe but all these rules were
wrong in that we just didn't know the
culture they were kind of like
fabrications that americans invented to
try to make themselves feel legitimate
about who got shot
you know but ultimately people saw
through this and said look we want to
see what's in practice is this the mere
group rule if it's dead it's vietnamese
it's vc any vietnamese we shoot we're
going to
count there's also the factor of racism
too i sure wonder how much they would
have done this if they'd been fighting
germany
it's probably much less of course
[ __ ] slope slant dink
one definition of a dead vietnamese was
believers
if they'd been napalmed they were called
crispy critters
and a one-liner went
when we killed a pregnant woman we
counted as two vc
one soldier and one cadet
now what you do is you load all the
friendlies the friendly vietnamese on
the ships
and take them out to the south china sea
and then you bomb the country flat
then
you sink the ships
i'd like to burn the whole country down
and then start again with americans
bomb the schools and churches bomb the
rice fields too
show the children in the courtyards just
what napalm can do
strafe the town and kill the people drop
their palm in the square
get out early every sunday and catch
them at their morning prayer
throw candy to the arvin
gather them all around
take your 20 millimeter cannon and mow
the bastards down
[Music]
yeah and this also
tapped a certain
sadism not only in soldiers in the field
but also intelligence people there were
people who would
collect ears and
fingers and even heads and even
intelligence people would
admit that they really got off to
beating up
the
people they were interrogating you know
gave him a nice buzz a thrill to do it
when you go through soldiers models and
memoirs many have made valiant efforts
to try to talk about the perverse
eroticism of warfare
um
a real you say it isn't clearly a very
strong status
dimensions a lot of rape
in the field as well as killing or a lot
of rapes followed by killings
and mutilations
well we'd um
we know maybe four or five of us we'd go
into the village and take a girl
and bring her out into the jungle
we'd tell her to lie on the ground and
don't scream otherwise we'd kill her
immediately
and then
well how many of her guys there were
well they did what they want to with her
as guys were in a good mood they let her
go
they weren't
they'd kill her
the girls were
unconscious
after they'd been repeatedly raped
and then after they got through raping
them three of the
gis took hand flares and they
shoved them in the girl's vaginas
the girls were bleeding from their
mouths noses and faces and vaginas
then the gis
lighted the exterior portion of the
flares
and
they exploded inside the girls
their stomachs just exploded
well one day i was driving back uh while
driving on a back road
and the guy comes over to me and he says
he needs some gasoline
didn't say why
well i look over and i see this girl and
she's stripped and she's tied to two
wooden stakes
i don't know what they'd done to her
before i got there
well they poured gasoline all over the
girl and they lighted it
they lit it and then they just stood
there
and watched her burn up
it's
it if you look at a body count system
and you see it that's the only thing
that counts
right the body count if that's that's
what rewards and punishments are
distributed by
if that's your ethic
and if your own command doesn't really
care
whether you survive
then clearly you're in a world where
anything goes
it becomes a bruise or it becomes where
it's apart
it becomes a war for survival or a war
to hold on to your ethics
i think a good example of this oliver
stone's movie platoon which is currently
in releasement shows a u.s military unit
that's severely defiant uh divided
between one group
who commits atrocities and others who
thinks it's a horrible horrible
situation and i think that's a good a
good illustration of probably the kind
of dynamics that occurred in many many
units it isn't as if everyone is a
killer
or or a sadist
it's as if you're in a structure
where
a significant component
of your troops engage in such behavior
but not everyone so it seems that then
you know we talk about atrocities and we
talk about me lie when you use that term
atrocity
it applies an exception to the existence
that's not a good way to look at it here
but may lie and atrocities were just
business as usual
yes
maylight seems a little well organized
and particularly well organized but
certainly
certainly male eye wasn't the only
village in vietnam that was burned down
where everybody inside it was shot that
is that that is that is not true at all
in fact bill is precisely this inability
on the ground war to distinguish between
friend and foe vc and peasant farmer
that led to the next dimension of techno
war the pacification
programs the fact that they weren't able
to
tell who the enemy was meant that they
had to clear out the whole country
certainly simply if you can't tell
friend from foe then you depopulate the
countryside and move them into refuge
into concentration camps and move them
into urban slums
it's not easy to depopulate a
countryside there are several major
techniques one is to feel affiliation
you simply destroy the food base of the
country this is where agent orange comes
in
agent orange and agent blue and agent
white were sprayed on millions of acres
of crop land
other millions of acres of forest were
defoliated so with the food base gone
people have to move
secondly
certainly bombing attacks
on villages which were quite quite
extensive discouraged encourage people
to move and then third actual search and
destroy operations where villages
some of which everyone has killed others
in which you simply surround the village
move everyone out then burn up the
village and move them remove them
there's three modes
millions and millions of vietnamese lost
their homes and were sent
to
concentration camps into urban slums and
what's so interesting is the americans
saw this progress this was urbanization
rural is bad urban is good
so
even though they have nothing
it was brought as a scene as a sign of
progress
to bring vietnamese in where
you could show them tv and
[Music]
make them work in american
bases and so on and so forth was seen as
having a more sophisticated job than
being a peasant farmer this is also part
of that same syndrome of not seeing the
enemy in the as
a culture or as as individuals or people
but seeing them just as mirror images of
ourselves
like the bombing of north vietnam was
supposed to hurt them if they destroyed
their capacity to have consumer goods
certainly and so the same idea
you would think from the american
perspective
that
no vietnamese cared about their home
that they didn't care about their land
and their dog and their ancestors grave
and their rice fields and their trees
that instead
simply just to have this new good have
this consumer go to live in the urban
area
but that in itself was just an
unmitigated good you're right people's
lives were not important the the human
dimension was completely lost and
instead in americans then we can count
how many tvs were imported this month
how many hondas yeah so the logic of
techno war was inapplicable to vietnam
in a way certainly that's exactly it
could in many ways it creates tremendous
destruction but it could not stop
a very powerfully united people who were
trying to change their lives in fact
this will be our topic for our next
program we're running out of time for
today and next week we'll see the
limitations of techno war of why it
failed in vietnam we'll also discuss
what's wrong with the liberal and
conservative interpretations of vietnam
we'll see what lessons we can draw from
the vietnam experience we also will talk
about some other aspects of the vietnam
war the tet offensive for instance that
was a big turning point in the war a lot
of revisionist historians particularly
conservatives said that it was an
american victory
was it or was it not we'll also talk
about this fascinating phenomenon in
which the american army pretty much
refused to fight or many elements in it
did as a matter of fact they started
attacking their own officers and senior
enlisted people
in this phenomenon known as fragging
and we'll conclude with a discussion of
some of the parallels to central america
of some of the failures of u.s policy in
central america and how they can be
illuminated by the failures of the
policy in vietnam so bill thanks for
coming tonight thanks doug this is an
interesting informative discussion and
we'll look forward to next week i'll be
there
thank you for watching alternative views
we'd like to thank our director david
galasich our audio person richard jones
our three camera people kelly sweeney
judy burton and brian lynch and of
course austin community television ac tv
alternative views is a production of the
alternative information network po box
7279
austin texas 787 13.
if you have any comments questions about
alternative views or suggestions
please write to us at this address
if you were a high vietnamese
general or colonel in the south
vietnamese government
army positions were like business
positions and it was most american aid
was on me it was for sale on the
international market by the time it
arrived the level of theft is
unbelievably high and the only reason
it's like rather than try to control the
theft
the american government essentially made
the decision look theft by the officer
corps is the price we have to pay for
continuing the war if you're a woman the
estimates are like a half million
vietnamese women engaged in some kind of
commercial sex
military war managers
devise ways to maximize sorting rates
it's like a factory you keep doing the
same routine
what this meant for pilots was that they
died the entire society was organized as
a giant anti-aircraft any aircraft
system
and it was really low level
vietnamese peasants were under
instructions
to simply get out in the fields in mass
lie down and shoot up in the air to try
to provide a barrage
that would make low
altitudes unsafe for american pilots and
it happened
from mid 68 on
the american military began to become
progressively more restless and by
certainly by late 69 and 70s an active
revolt against its commanders
so people begin what's called fragging
fragging means you take a fragmentation
grenade and you throw it at your
superior
whether it's a non-commissioned officer
sergeant or a lieutenant or a captain or
whatever it was a way to tell higher
command
not to treat the ground troops lives
frivolously my analysis says the u.s had
to get out because we couldn't fight
because we had an army that wouldn't do
it anymore
the second in our two-part series on the
vietnam war
featuring the author of the book the
perfect war
we find out if the military-industrial
complex has learned anything tonight on
alternative view
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
guys would come in and they'd say no
more than
i'm tired of fighting this war
i try to find out what the war
meant to them what it was like
including some of the guilt
and all they'd say was
i've done a lot of killing
and i'm not sure it's right
well they'd been on sweeps of villages
with orders to leave nothing living not
even chickens or water buffaloes
well what did that mean following orders
like that
wasn't
lieutenant cali and me lie wasn't it
that stirred up this in the first place
hell they were doing a me lie every day
they'd be out on a mission and call in
air strikes
napalm would be sprayed
and the people would be burning
sometimes they'd put them out of their
misery
the guys who did that are still coming
into the veterans centers
with this on their mind
12 years later
welcome to alternative views this is the
second on our two-part series
about the vietnam war
with bill gibson who wrote an incredible
book about the vietnam war called the
perfect war techno war
in his book the perfect war techno war
in vietnam was recently published by
atlantic monthly press and has so far
received some extremely good reviews it
was favorably reviewed in the wall
street journal kirkus review described
it as a perceptive cogent significant
and so far the best analysis of the
meaning of america's only military
defeat highly recommended gloria emerson
in a review described the book as
although many valuable books on the war
exist as records of pain and endurance
there is no work that achieves what this
does because he might just save us from
our most comfortable lies and sad
delusions william gibson should be
honored and john stockwell describes
this book as in all of my research on
the subject i found nothing to compare
with dr gibson's perfect war for
invaluable insights into u.s methodology
and its hideous results in the war
tonight we're going to talk about
the things we didn't cover
we're going to talk about tet the
importance of that the tet offensive
we're going to talk about how the united
states army
a lot of them didn't
they decided they weren't going to fight
that war anymore
we're going to have an evaluation of the
vietnam war how many how do people look
at it
from various aspects and we'll also take
a final look at have we learned our
lessons are we still inviting fighting
techno war in central america or at
least planning to
what is your interpretation of techno
war how do we get involved in vietnam
techno war means you fight war as a
production process
the military became deeply impressed
with big businesses contributions of
world war ii
after world war ii the military then
decided that not only would the supply
operations be organized along corporate
lines but that actual conduct of warfare
would be organized along corporate lines
the officer corps were the managers the
enlisted men were the workers the
product was enemy body count just as
american business prided itself on high
technology capital intensive production
systems so too would our military have
high technology capital intensive
warfare to out produce
we would kill more of them than they
would of us
that's techno war why was it applied in
vietnam
because
after world war in the 50s the soviets
had the atomic bomb they could then
destroy our economy
at the base of our power if we intervene
militarily in the war in the world with
too much force the object then was to
fight limited war for indefinitely in
the third world we would use our we
would just send our production system
over there and drive the other side
bankrupt
why vietnam americans saw
communism not as another type of social
organization as another culture as
another
political system but instead they saw
americans as the good the natural
the god-like and the communism was a
foreign other an alien kind of being the
world was divided into simply two types
of people communist and non-communist
and therefore it was like debit or
credit their side or our side
by the time the vietnamese overthrew the
french in the late 50s we had our theory
of limited war intact we had our
conventional forces ready to go by the
late 50s vietnam was simply a convenient
mode place to test out this new theory
of warfare techno war and a place to
drive the foreign other back in fact you
pointed out something fascinating in
your book about how a major part of u.s
supported a certain part of the war was
to win the hearts and the minds of the
vietnamese
through importing u.s commodities to
them yes the u.s government actually put
up the money to
import these commodities and created the
whole infrastructure for it and rather
than winning the hearts and minds of the
overwhelming majority of the vietnamese
people it just created more corruption
and inequality do you want to talk about
that aspect of you it's just hard for us
to realize how much money was poured
into that country in so many ways
if you were a high vietnamese
general or colonel in the south
vietnamese government
army positions were like business
positions and it was most american aid
was on me it was
for sale on the international market by
the time it arrived the level of theft
is unbelievably high and the only reason
it's like rather than try to control the
theft
the american government essentially made
the decision look theft by the officer
corps is the price we have to pay for
continuing the war
so therefore in order that something
reaches the vietnamese people will just
send more and more and more
and there was an element of truth in
that but also the greater truth was that
simply corruption became compounded and
the riches became became greater we're
talking about millions and millions upon
hundreds of millions of dollars made or
even
currency manipulation currency fraud was
endemic if you knew how to play the game
you could get rich
simply by exchanging your money from
from dollars to pastors to military
script and back again
you know just nothing just by playing
playing with the rules a little bit
so
but it didn't
it created massive inflation
it meant that life for most people got
worse it's
what were your jobs available while a
few people on top were able to make
money off this this uh stealing the
american aid on the bottom what were
your jobs open for you
well you could work for the americans
you could work on their base
you could be an interpreter maybe if you
had minimal language skills these are
all if you're a man if you're a woman
the estimates are like a half million
vietnamese women engaged in some kind of
commercial sex
prostitution massage parlors however you
want to call it hooch girls there's a
whole
multi-level sexual marketplace
drugs
drugs the drugs
huge huge heroin
importation coming from all places
coming from laos and the cia was running
a war in laos with
the hills people and with the laotian
government in order to buy the leaders
of the hills people and buy the laotian
government they had to acquiesce to the
heroin trade
tons of heroin were brought in on air
america planes and vietnamese air force
planes were refined in bangkok and other
places and sold on in two u.s soldiers
in vietnam
south vietnamese civil and military
leadership was also heavily involved in
the narcotics business general and
subsequent president of the republic of
vietnam win bantu ran one major
operation while when kyle key
the times air marshal premier and vice
president ran another
for orphans what could you do
shoe shine business wasn't something
kids had to make money on the side
shining shoes was life or death issue
going through garbage dumps
you know a very dismal life in this new
urban vietnam not a consumer paradise
and then the other hand you had the
black market
where as you say in your book you could
buy anything you can buy tanks armored
personnel carriers and of course the
viet cong were tapping they quit
themselves whenever they needed american
goods they could equip themselves
without any problem the other aspect of
u.s policy was air war part of your most
brilliant chapters and descriptions in
your book are of the magnitude and
nature of the air war in vietnam that
was mainly i guess directed against
north vietnam do you want to discuss
some elements of air war
if war is a factory
then clearly when you look at air war
we've got the biggest factory and they
have nothing
by american reasoning the north
vietnamese should have given up the day
the first bombs dropped on north vietnam
because they had such a small small
industrial apparatus
such a small
number of bridges and things that you
would think they would have just given
up
but
they didn't
um
they were willing to sacrifice their
industrial apparatus they were willing
to absorb a massive mass of casualties
and indeed
contrary to american
mythology where the vietcong were simply
being totally supported from the north
roughly
eighty percent of the supplies the
vietcong used and even the eighty
percent of supplies the nva used were
raised in the south a small number of
supplies were sent south it couldn't be
stopped
no matter how hard the u s bombed
no matter how much it escalated its
campaigns
no matter even after they closed the
ports at haifang and started
systematically bombing the railroad
lines between china and vietnam it
couldn't stop it the number of supplies
wasn't that great on the other hand the
air war didn't mobilize the north
vietnamese people
to a considerable degree
of everyone had a job of one kind or
another either repairing the railroads
repairing the roads or taking over
industry or working in agriculture so it
mobilized and consolidated that society
to
carry on much like the nazi attack on
great britain
consolidated british morale in world war
ii but on the other hand people used to
say well we ought to bomb them back to
the stone age and we just practically
did didn't we most people don't
recognize that
the united states air force and navy
dropped between 8 million and 15 million
tons of bombs and rockets on southeast
asia in all of world war ii the united
states dropped 2.1 million tons
so the minimum estimate then is about
four times greater than world war ii and
it goes up to almost eight times greater
than world war ii
and
in westmoreland's 1967 report he has a
target category summary and the largest
category in there after vehicles is
buildings
when you listen to the reports of
foreign observers on the ground what
they report is just about any modern
stone or brick structure over to two
story over one story was hit
because those were the only things that
looked like targets and in essence a lot
of those were churches a lot of them
were hospitals a lot of them were
schools yes north vietnam was bombed
back to the stone age there's no doubt
about that but because they were not
fighting a techno war
that
now we saw in the previous program
where this
production assembly line type of
attitude
resulted in the demand for body count
for the land troops
in the air war
they also had production quotas did they
not and the organization of this
was all right the unit of measurement is
called a sortie that's one fight by one
airplane
and air force squadrons wings air force
large units have rates of production
that they are supposed to meet the navy
and the air force and indeed were in
common in competition with each other to
see you could quote be the most
productive
therefore the the object was to fly as
many missions as possible within a
finite period of time like a week or a
month or whatever
so rather than then pay attention to
really what you were bombing or to pay
attention to
the safest way to
protect your pilots and the way to
minimize civilian casualties
instead
military war managers
devised ways to maximize sorting rates
and consequently
entered into serious
irrational behavior
they liken ground war where u.s
commander treated their own ground
troops as expendable higher command
treated pilots is expendable they would
often be sent on missions
on say looking for trucks in the middle
of rainstorms when it's impossible to
see trucks from fighting because the
ground you know you can't even see the
ground when you're 500 feet above it but
that keeps the sorting rate high
or also say you're supposed to you know
it's raining over a given target and
it's the target's clouding in but you
still send your planes up there every
day five days in a row by the exact same
road
in order so that because that's simply
it's like a factory you keep doing the
same routine
well we sure telegraphed our punches
there weren't all that many targets in
that area and it didn't take too many
smarts to figure out about where the air
force was headed
especially when we
headed them there day after day
making them fly up to the target before
making the go or no-go decision on the
weather that we already knew was not
acceptable
then we turned over the target and came
back again the next day
to try again
what this meant for pilots was that they
died because the vietnamese clearly
understood where the americans were
flying the same pattern every day and
they understood that
they would just keep coming so what
often frequently vietnamese did was
simply move more and more anti-aircraft
guns into an area that the americans for
some reason wanted to bomb and what
ended up is american pilots ended up
just fighting
flying missions against empty targets
surrounded by hundreds and hundreds of
anti-aircraft weapons and in this way
by telegraphing our punches
american pilots died
i talked with a couple of nearly
apoplectic f-4 pilots at da nang who
told me then god they'd gone out
recently on a on a four plane mission
carrying a very small bomb load
one pilot told me he was gritting his
teeth he was so mad we risked eight guys
he said
when we could have hung the whole load
on one plane risking only two people
and done the job better
well then i asked him well why did they
send out four planes
the pilot said damned if i know
unless it's just to keep our sortie rate
high
but i tell you this it's a god damn
crime
well you know i heard about this sortie
business on aircraft carrier
constellation the navy pilots who told
me they could do a better job with a few
a6s operating in the safety of darkness
than with all those skyhawks skimming
around with light loads in daylight
so while it didn't seem possible it
appeared that the navy was trying to
outsource the air force and the air
force was trying to outsort the navy
the guys who were flying the sorties
took a dim view of it
you had an incredible story in your book
or
about how the north vietnamese would
actually bring down the american jets
with handguns and rifles that almost
seems unbelievable to us in a
in an advanced from an american
standpoint it is unbelievable in that
you only see advanced technology system
like a jet fighter bomber needs another
advanced technology like a sand missile
in order to bring it down
and there is a lot of some amount of
truth in that but north vietnam
underwent a tremendous social
mobilization part of that mobilization
involved giving almost everyone a gun
either a pistol a submachine gun a rifle
or whatever or light machine guns the
entire society was organized as a giant
anti-aircraft any aircraft system
and it was really low level
vietnamese peasants were under
instructions
to simply get out in the fields in mass
lie down and shoot up in the air to try
to provide a barrage that would make low
altitudes unsafe for american pilots and
it happened
american fighter pilots do report
that several many planes were shot down
an extremely low level
by peasants and what this meant to them
low-level flight became so dangerous
they had to move higher up where they
could consistently be picked up on radar
in other words it isn't just that
peasants could shoot down planes just
that but they denied an airspace to
americans that made all air operations
had more hazardous
so social mobilization was able to
compensate for technological inferiority
there was another example of this
in the ho chi minh trail when the united
states built that incredibly expensive
electronic warfare area
which the
they were able which the
vietnamese and the oceans were able to
overcome with very simple tricks the
joint chiefs of staff always wanted to
invade north vietnam
and simply take over hanoi and hypong or
have ground troops in laos there is a
place where
between laos and thailand between the
the south china sea and thailand
something like 35 miles and so wide so
the effort is
the mission was we'll just form on this
magic line and we'll keep the foreign
other out right we'll stop them at the
pass after you know literally
but since uh that was seen as too
expensive in terms of troop lies they
seated that area with electronic sensors
listening devices devices that picked up
smell
sensors of various kinds
these devices in turn sent radio signals
to circling aircraft the aircraft in
turn sent them to computer banks in
thailand in thailand in turn organized
airstrikes over the trail
but two things happened
one
the sensors were decoyed
bags of urine hung in trees tape
recorders with cricket noises in order
to try to mask the movement of trucks
you find a sensor and you put normal
jungle noises a tape of normal jungle
noises next to it
um so you mask the sensors in one area
while you actually send your troops and
operations on the other or
uh say you get attacked and uh you were
all
convoy drivers truck drivers north
vietnamese had satchels of grenades they
had rocket flares
a lot of this is battle is occurring at
night so the vietnamese would throw out
explosives to make the americans feel
like they were hitting something
and the americans in turn wanted to
believe that they were destroying
vietnamese truck convoys why
because pilots are rewarded on the basis
of productivity
they're majors and lieutenant colonels
most of them want to be full colonels
and probably as some are desperately
want to be brigadier generals they need
to be productive
therefore their their tendency is to
report
as high a destruction of trucks as
possible
and the big joke eventually became in in
intelligence
was that the next day when
reconnaissance flights would fly out
along the ho chi minh trail they could
never find the truck carcasses in
anywhere near the numbers
that
the pilots reported destroyed
so the legend began that deep in the
laotian jungles live
the great
truck eater
[Laughter]
and the great truck eater was a monster
that totally loved dead trucks and that
and it lives a nocturnal beast and that
every night it got up and it ate the
skeletons of dread dead trucks so that
when the reconnaissance planes came out
in the morning there would simply be no
records
this is not to say thousands of trucks
were destroyed but never to the extent
necessary
remember
relatively few supplies were sent south
by american calculations
something like 12 tons a day was enough
to support the war in the south you can
put 12 tons on a semi-tractor truck
without any problem and has room to
spare
or even if you multiply it by figure 15
or 20 folds say so you have 20 tractor
trailer trucks a day on the ho chi minh
trail or 40 pickups or whatever
that's still such a small number that
even a very extensive air war has a hard
time or cannot stop that level of
supplies bill most of the military
generals and participants in the war
whose memoirs you read and documents you
studied indicated that the us really won
most of the battles of the war that the
u.s their records yes right was on its
way to victory and in particular there's
a right-wing revisionist view that the
u.s could have won the war at the time
of the tet offensive at the u.s buildup
of maine corps main force units ground
troops began in 65 by the end of 67
we had somewhat over four hundred
thousand i think 450 000 maybe even as
high as five hundred thousand troops in
country
according to american records
the official rectors kept in the
pentagon and kept at military assistance
command vietnam we had just about
destroyed all the vietcong troops they
were all nearly decimated
now why was that because our records
were falsified
as we began let's talk i talked about
last time once you move into war's
production process and the officers are
managers
they lose their sense of fidelity to
their subordinates below and sense of
their fidelity of the truth upward
mobility just like in business where man
would be going up you know up the high
ladder is the name of the game that was
the latter in the military
the currency in warfare was to report
the body count so everybody
upped their body count
fake body counts were routine not the
not the exceptional
and at each level
they were the body counts kept getting
higher and higher as the reports went up
the chain of command the larger the
figures became
well the first report i would send in
was from the facts from the information
we collected and it was subjective as it
would yes it could be
then we sent it in but then it would
always come back doctored up from higher
headquarters that was standard operating
procedure
when i was brigade historian there so
the result is that the battle news
was edited and revised until it was
acceptable to the higher ups
well i've been ordered to write open
lies on our civil aid programs such as
increasing the 15 english classes of 300
to make it look good to the politicians
and the people back home and i've been
ordered to raise the figures for food
distribution in refugee villages
but i've also had to re-type battle
reports
omitting a certain facts
and thereby turning a north vietnam army
victory over superior american forces
into a u.s victory
so on paper we had won
but in reality two things are that was
part one of our victory the second point
was
in 1967 the american higher command
decided that vietcong guerrillas no
longer existed because
and so they abolished them on paper
because just like american forces we
don't have any part-time guerrillas or
full-time gorillas and also do gorillas
have 50 to have tanks do gorillas have
helicopters do gorillas have
heavy artillery they don't have as much
hardware as we do so they aren't really
a threat to american units
so several hundred thousand
are
vietcong guerrillas were abolished from
what's called the order of battle
so once you eliminate the guerrillas on
paper and then you
so you have a lower total estimate
of enemy forces
and you have an inflated
estimate of how many of those you've
killed
while we'd won
lyndon johnson desperately needed a
political victory in the fall of 67. so
he got general westmoreland to come back
and say we're winning we're winning that
we're soon going to enter in into phase
three and that is uh we're going to mop
up for a couple years
and what was happening in reality
in reality the vietcong forces the
native the local forces had expanded
radically from 1964 through late 1967.
according to u s figures there were only
about two hundred thousand viet cong
but when one c i a man started like
going through the files and trying to
re-figure things he calculated about a
half million let's understand what that
means if the cia man is doubling hid the
estimate that essentially means they
don't have any idea of how many of them
are there but it means a double is
probably the highest figure he can get
away with
and still
be listened to by anyone
so
in reality the enemy is gaining strength
we have with through the viet cong we
have north vietnamese participation
still around 50 000 troops a year being
sent south in the border zones along the
cambodia and laotian borders and in
certain offset
the
i-corps the north of the country
in the u.s strategic offensive had
failed of search and destroy the bombing
operations had failed
in late january early february 1968 the
north this beg your pardon the vietcong
forces attacked in mass
simultaneously for the first time
normally
they fought very dispersed operations
they were not under your under
not under no those this was the first
time there'd been a simultaneous
national attack
the attack succeeded in driving
one it ended the pacification war all
the units involved in pacification were
driven out of the countryside into the
cities almost all of the vietnamese and
american ground force units were driven
out of the countryside back into the
cities to
defend the cities there and some
vietcong forces entered cities
saigon way
regional capitals and we began to battle
in the cities
now what happened
after a few weeks
the vietcong withdrew from the cities
their casualties were extremely high
they had not anticipated that the
americans would bomb and conduct
artillery strikes inside the cities
but they did so a large part of south
vietnam was reduced to rubble
their casualties were high but
the americans and south vietnamese
arvind units were gone from the
countryside
desertions had been massive
and
the econ were able to recruit many many
many people now that there were no
opposing forces in the countryside their
political cadres were able to surface so
they were weakened in many ways but in
the other hand they had achieved a
decisive victory in driving
their opponents out of the countryside
now from
what is the legend then
because american forces
were able to
kill many of the commandos and vietcong
troops inside the cities
the americans of general westbourne
declared victory
uh
of course this ignores the fact that
although he's driven the vietcong out of
the cities he himself has been driven
out of the countryside and that has made
a mockery out of his own previous claims
of victory
also as far as clear to many many people
that there were far more
enemies
in south vietnam than the americans have
been willing to admit
westmoreland then made a troop request
for another 200 000 soldiers
this recruit request went under severe
analysis
essentially what was found
was that if within the production model
of war if you were just gonna fight the
same kind of warfare but simply add more
resources to it still the viet cong
alone just the people in the south
could fight on for another four or five
years or at least three years to four
years and then with any north or with
significant north vietnamese
participation they could fight on 10 to
20 years
and which you just we just could not
drive the other side bankrupt and you're
saying that the north vietnamese army
basically hadn't participated not in
touch not intent the north vietnamese
army did not participate in tech okay in
fact in most of the war they really
played a minimal role when you consider
the number of vietcong troops in
proportion to the number of north
vietnamese well that's true
up until 68 after 68 they entered the
war in larger numbers
the vietcong were hit in other words
certainly
the conservative claim that vietcong
took severe losses in the ted offensive
is true the claim that they were
decimated and defeated as false and the
claim that the americans won tet is
false
ted essentially made help the american
war managers at least the part of them
see that their strategy was bankrupt and
that there was no path to victory
so this finally created a remember linda
johnson resigned somewhere during this
period that's right not too long
afterward was this kind of a break in
their self-delusion that techno war
would win everything ah now here is a
serious problem that people do not
understand
american television news began from
night from late 1968 on began to report
the idea that the war was winding down
and that we were on our way out
this is not true this is a false
statement you should never believe this
when you look at the casualty figures of
how many american soldiers were killed
from 65 through 68 for 60 through 67
and then you take 68 and then you look
69 through 73.
the 69 through 73 is just about is
within a couple of hundred
as high as the number of killed
65 through 67.
search and destroy continued way way on
until until
oh late 71. what was it then that
finally convinced the u.s foreign policy
establishment or the u.s public that
vietnam couldn't be won
from mid-68 on
the american military began to become
progressively more restless and by
certainly by late 69 70s an active
revolt against its commanders
remember that 75 percent of the battles
in vietnam were initiated by the enemy
and the average american grunts spent
his tour of duty that those few who were
combat troops spent his tour of duty
walking into ambushes
um
most men learned fairly quickly that
while they were walking in ambushes that
their generals were getting medals and
they were safe in helicopters and so on
and so forth
so pimple begin what's called fragging
fragging means you take a fragmentation
grenade and you throw it at your
superior
whether it's a non-commissioned officer
sergeant or a lieutenant or a captain or
whatever it was a way to tell higher
command not to treat the ground troops
lives frivolously that they would not
pursue aggressively pursue dangerous
combat situations that
simply in order to make the to make the
superiors look good
well let me tell you how it worked we'd
start having war calls which is like uh
oh well at midnight everybody in the
outfit starts opening fire and screaming
gooks on the wire gooks on the wire and
the barbed wire fences you know and then
you try to kill any of the lifers that
you didn't like
so we tried to get the co a couple of
times with the machine gun one time his
uh rack took nine holes his cot nine
bullet holes but he dove out of it and
got away everybody'd be shooting so he
couldn't check the weapon see who was
shooting at him so they'd be throwing
grenades at the wire and yelling and
shouting gooks on the wire gooks and
they'd blow the siren and then run
around and have the guys be facing out
where it's shooting and then the other
half would be waiting for a lifer to
come out of his tent
yeah i've seen
the officers executed five or six times
just put a price on his head
next one that kills him gets the money
next time he was out on a mission
everybody knew it was going to happen
they just wait till he was
in the right position
and the estimates run quite high and
there was the official army count as
about 650 fragging incidents
and
there are real reasons to doubt that
because it's been quite small i'm sure
there were a lot of them that weren't
reported oh of course because no
commander wants to have what do you say
it's like somebody my men threw a
grenade at me or tried to shoot me i
mean how is that going to look good on
your record are you going to get
promoted up as a great leader when
you're reporting that your own people
are shooting at you no i'm sure the
records are the figures must be
substantially higher the soldiers even
put pools of money out for contracts for
particularly unpopular
officers but there's also suicide and
self mutilation that went on too
people would have got desperate if they
were it's the
they were disoriented they were not
being cared for by their own command the
actual operations often involve
slaughter of innocents
suicide rates are fairly high
standing up in the middle of firefight
there's one famous uh cartoon book by a
man named tadd forester
and
it shows a picture of a man of a soldier
hiding behind a rock with his trigger
finger in the air looking for the
million dollar wound the thing being
like if he exposed this and got his
index finger shot off that he could get
out of the war zone or you don't take
your malaria pill
we're not going to get him
therefore removed because you're
incapacitated with malaria there are
many many ways of people shooting
themselves in the foot there are lots
and lots of stories of self-mutilation
or you do it to your friend
in other words if your friend is saying
been wounded twice
and you're on a particularly dangerous
mission and he's had a premonition of
death
which was taken very very seriously all
combat soldiers are deeply superstitious
then sometimes you shoot or you you you
stab your friend not not in a vital
place but to wound them enough to get
them out
you
can't fight a war this way you cannot
fight a war where people are are you
going search and avoid also yeah search
and avoid that's a very that was a very
prevalent thing too instead of search
and destroy search and a void that is
you you go out and you you play you play
war you try to like you go out and you
smoke some dope and you fake some radio
reports or you generally try not to
engage the enemy yes
we talked about it every day
all the guys felt the same way
we just weren't accomplishing anything
in fact some guys were so depressed and
disgusted they was killing themselves
some guys were taking hand grenades and
blowing themselves away
they couldn't take the strain anymore
god is really heavy
i don't think a lot of this stuff was
reported
gis would just kill themselves
the army would probably send the stats
home that the guy was killed or
missing in action
and did the anti-war movement at home
have any effect on these soldiers in
creating a sense of what that what they
were doing was wrong that they were
victims they were making mistakes did
that have impact do you think on this
there was a wide coffee house gi coffee
house movement the anti-war movement
tried to set up coffee houses near u.s
bases to
promote literature and things
but honestly when you read
soldiers memoirs and novels they
honestly don't talk about the anti-war
movement very much it's not to say there
wasn't an influence but they talk about
reacting
to the situation of warfare that they're
in the one that uh
uh and in the in what the moral qualms
are the moral qualms that are seen on
the battlefield the one clear influence
of the anti-war movement is nobody would
be the last man to die in vietnam i mean
once it was
stated that the u.s was going to
withdraw eventually that made it more
difficult
there was one place in your book where
you said that this actually was a class
war class warfare that was going on and
that black
black soldiers
were at the forefront of the fragging
and the revolt
let's remember who went to vietnam
after world war ii the u.s military
decided that too many college-educated
men had been killed and the danger of
this was that it was going to hurt the
scientific base of the country if the
scientific base was the country was hurt
we couldn't have the next generation of
weapons so the idea of the 2s deferment
of the college deferment was to keep the
pool alive
what this meant was remember this is an
era of very few student loans very few
scholarships so and so forth it meant
that the sons of the middle class could
go to college where the sons of the
working class
went to
the military
in the military
itself military needs vast numbers of
white collar skills so if you had any
kind of like
clerical skills like middle class people
do often do typing filing so on you
could ease more readily get a non-combat
job
what this translated into is that when
she started got down to the point of who
was in your infantry units your armor
and artillery
they were overwhelmed they were
disproportionately minorities and rural
whites
poor worldwide poor urban whites so we
had a working class
largely working class
military combat military whereas a more
middle class anti-war movement and more
middle-class logistic apparatus
in in the military so as a class revolt
a class revolt no i wouldn't call it
revolution we're not talking about these
people we're not socialists now but it
is sort of like uh let's revolt against
the manager yes it's not in our interest
they're exploiting and using us yes and
yeah and then certainly with among black
soldiers
they were definitely influenced by the
black power movement racial
consciousness and critical consciousness
was very paramount and there were many
of the tie signs of bonding signs of you
know the
skin and special handshakes so on and so
forth how would you evaluate the mass
media handling of
vietnam then and now
i spent a long time looking at the tapes
and i was closed it's like i'd finished
my outline i was going to write a book
about television news coverage the war
and i started to think well what was not
on the news frame
what i saw and that's constantly i wrote
this other book the perfect war
what's on the news
is a lot of pictures of helicopters a
lot of pictures of jets a lot of
pictures of tanks a lot of hardware and
which techno war was the major
representation to visual representation
and along with these products these
these presentations of these beautiful
weapons i remember my favorite
was an abc show an abc series where they
first went out and they see the
battleship new jersey battleship new
jersey had just been recommissioned in
69 and we see here's this 16 16-inch
guns and there's this giant 30-foot
phallus that the camera looks down and
guy starts talking about it shoots a
250-pound projectile 16 miles it'll go
through 32 feet of reinforced concrete
or maybe they have that the other way
maybe it's 32 miles 16 feet of
reinforced country i forget it's a 250
yard kill radius and it's simply like
the man is the the correspondent become
a salesperson
and like i thought gosh i too want the
battleship in new jersey you know this
is just cool beyond belief and then the
film cuts and there's another
correspondent and he's on the the bank
of a river and it's about the vc fling
flying trash can
and if you remember the
road runner rockets you know about wiley
coyote was always getting something from
acme rocket company that always kind of
looked like a trash can on a stick with
a kind of like triangle on top of it
that's exactly
what this rocket looked like was
obviously of a homemade crude rocket
and the contrast is so great and it
seems like american victory is so
insured because we're of our technical
superiority of course what they don't
point out the vietcong who fires that
rocket knows exactly what he's shooting
at was the battleship in new jersey very
rarely knew
where its bullets were flying
so that's what the people saw people saw
that people did not not see very many
dead people there were very few
the the death convention on the news was
much like a war movie or western's
no no real gore and they saw a body
count each week which showed that we
were always winning we saw one village
one village was burned in 1965 that's it
and the guy in the correspondent got in
severe trouble um may lie up here it is
is remember did not come from the news
of it didn't come from the normal
networks it came from a veteran who
tried hard to get the news out very
little coverage of massachusetts came on
the ordinary language of the war [ __ ]
slope slant dink no american news
correspondent ever talked about those
terms and what they meant
never it simply did not occur instead it
was very much an official perspective
where it one got critical from 68 on
occasionally you would see reports
about failed technology
and occasionally you would see stories
about tragic american deaths
but it was sort of like a human interest
tragedy becomes the limit of criticism
rather than any kind of explanatory
notion of why we aren't succeeding bill
let's talk about evaluation of the
vietnam war a lot of people have written
books about it historians and generals
etc
well let's let's end it just to come
back to where we started to this other
point
my analysis says the u.s had to get out
because we couldn't fight because we had
an army that wouldn't do it anymore now
you could you could move to air force
campaigns but air force campaigns have
their problems too you can't hold ground
with airplanes
sending money to the south vietnamese
they were corrupt they just had more
money to be corrupt with so we were
defeated my analysis says the united
states was defeated and that that's
that's the standpoint so the question is
how have the historians and the
novelists and so on treated the subject
of american defeat
the conventional path is a liberal
interpretation that is it's just a
tragedy it's just things were wrong out
there somewhere and like it's just like
there were all sorts of small mistakes
of honorable men making small small
decisions
author sessions would be the most famous
the classical case stanley carnell's
book and pbs series the most recent
example
but the notion of tragedy is not an
explanation you know 20 years of
smallmouth snakes doesn't explain a war
that has a very clear structure which is
my argument that the structural
contradictions of that mode of warfare
ended in its dissolution and failure
the second school the most prominent
right now is that u s lost because of
self-imposed restraints
self-imposed restraints is a military
term
often used in joint chiefs of staff
documents calling for escalated air war
and their vision is that the united
states should have invaded north vietnam
in 1966
and taken hanoi and haifang of course
the only problem with that are every one
of those peasants who had those guns
fighting against shooting against the
aircraft the jet fighter pilots they
were also organized and prepared for
invasion doug you mentioned why you know
you mentioned the fact that the north
vietnamese didn't have very many troops
in the south that was one of the major
reasons it wasn't that they didn't want
to help their comrades and their
southern comrades it was troops were
being held back
in part to protect the home front
against a possible american invasion
according to giap
the plan for you to fight a u.s invasion
was to let local militia and regional
forces fight for the first day to two
days
so once the americans were tired
after 24 to 48 hours of constant combat
then the north vietnamese army would
enter the scene and was this notion that
the u.s could have had a successful
invasion it's just the
the most
bizarre
unreal fantasy unworthy of any kind of
serious consideration and even if they
had put an expeditionary force in hanoi
and haifang we still let one change the
class structure in south vietnam that
wouldn't change the fact that you had a
peasantry that wanted land that you
wanted buddhist who wanted
self-determination rather than catholic
rule and that you wanted that a whole
country wanted national reunification
because the whole basis of the culture
was throwing out the foreign invader and
that's all they'd done all their lives
for two thousand years was throughout
the chinese the french and now the
americans that was it it wouldn't have
changed it the self-imposed restraint
still is false well have we learned
anything since then we you point out the
total
corruption and self-delusion of the
military and the civilian leaders
throughout this
first of all thinking they could wage a
techno war and secondly having not
paying attention to
the realities which might try to seep up
from the intelligence field
suppressing any intelligence that would
contrary would contrary to what they
wanted
are we still in that same mode of
thinking yes do we are we thinking of
applying it to
well we already have a couple places
certainly grenada was one example we
took grenada
and we just barely took it even though
there was a minimum opposition most of
the u.s special forces commandos bit the
dust in various operations because of
various mishaps of one kind or another
also the military's analysis is well not
only did we fight with one high untied
behind our back but we fought too slow
we needed more rapid escalation
so honduras has been prepared a series
of airfields and ports have been
prepared in honduras in order to bring
40 50 000 troops into battle within a
week
they have the facilities for this
and they still have many in the military
have the illusion that they could
probably take managua and a few other
places in a couple of weeks
rather than an extensive
central american war which would
escalate tremendously because the
nicaraguans had their of no choice
except to expand the war outside of
nicaragua to make the battlefield bigger
if the battlefield's bigger then the
united states has to disperse its troops
if its dispersed troops are dispersed
you can't achieve victory back to
vietnam back to vietnam sounds like they
haven't learned a thing they have not
learned a thing
but there are
most haven't learned a thing there are
mayor veterans of course in the u.s who
now who
certainly don't want to see this there
are probably parts of the military in
very subordinate positions who don't
want to see a major escalation but
generally we're on track for another
kind of a major intervention whether or
not it will be since the iran agua
crisis has emerged
that may be off for a while i don't know
but there's certainly philippines
there's another growing insurgency there
the chan the chances for another major
intervention and another series of self
delusions are very very high because the
people the officer corps who were
successful in vietnam or the people who
are in charge now the people who were
the dissidents
the the few handfuls of lieutenant
colonels and majors who were three just
got repulsed they got out
they resigned most of them did
ironically the army itself recognized
this in 1970 in a war college study
which indicated that
there is a significant difference
between the ideal army values such as
honesty integrity bravery justice and
responsibility
and the real values which are practiced
by the military in order to promote
career advancement
here is the study's conclusion
the present climate does not appear to
be self-correcting
the human drives for success and
recognition by seniors
sustained if not inflamed by the system
of rewards and management which cater to
immediate personal success
at the expense of moral and ethical
values
would appear to only be perpetuated by
the current environment
the fact alone that the leaders of the
future are those who survived and
excelled within the rules of the present
system militates in part against any
self-starting incremental return toward
the practical application of ideal army
values
then the final reason i note the problem
of learning is that there are cultural
reasons that make the american people
want to believe the self-imposed
restraint school and that is we are used
to the addition of the cowboy who comes
in and saves the society against the
enemies when the power structure cannot
defend itself
the idea of a weak authority that has to
be saved by a warrior shows up in many
places in american culture in the
western in the detective hero the
detective hero is outside the law
all the superman and the masked avenger
figures of the 20s and 30s certainly are
able to foil criminals that
legal authorities cannot
um but also there isn't a deep belief
that technology cannot fail certainly in
american culture that if we have enough
technological or military force we can't
help but win a war
it's people it's hard not to believe in
your hardware americans don't learn
about social relations they don't learn
about class structure every day in the
newspaper or about cultural history
every day in the newspaper they learn
about what's for sale
then what is the lesson of vietnam
concerning the limits of techno war the
situations in which technology can
destroy but it cannot achieve victory
it can destroy land it can destroy
people but it can't create a government
it can't create a culture it can't
create a society
i mean this was another thing we tried
to do in vietnam to impose the model of
the consumer society on them and
american style supposed democracy
whether it be elections in situations
where these just couldn't work
oh
well it did work in a way and there was
yeah people can become corrupted they
did get into their drugs and their
hondas and things but it just doesn't
build a stable society it doesn't build
uh
it doesn't real people who are willing
to die for that society that was the
whole problem they had you had plenty of
corrupted vietnamese but when it looks
like things were near they weren't
willing to go out and defend saigon to
the death or not they just did they
bought their tickets out to the united
states whereas the peasants were willing
to fight to death just for land yes and
just for getting rid of their landlords
or local oppressors it made perfect
sense to them and there's been this
problem the so-called vietnam syndrome
which our leaders have been complaining
about all these years
as if there was a sickness in the land
the loss of will to fight yes
and but it looks like the american
had a clearer picture of what the war
was all about than the than the leaders
but what you how would you assess that
and do you think that they were
overcoming that vietnam syndrome now so
that they can well i don't think the
american public ever had an idea what
was wrong they just knew something was
wrong and that it wasn't getting better
i think i think indeed their fuzziness
made it easier for people to believe the
self-imposed restraint school to believe
that we lost because we didn't fight
hard enough
for the past for the past few years
popular culture has presented the hero
that the warrior imagery is well very
much strong on the rise we've had many
classical war movies made and several
kind of variant war movies made
it's definitely a war culture
how people though
clearly though there's there's still a
resistance there's still a certain level
in which the disaster of vietnam is
etched in at least some people's
memories and even though it's if they
don't have an understanding of why it
failed or what the structural reasons
there is a fear that
it will happen again
in bill gibson's book the perfect war
he quotes tim o'brien's novel going
after cacciato about the difficulty of
determining reality for americans in
vietnam
here's what he said
they did not know even the simple things
a sense of victory
or satisfaction
or necessary sacrifice
they didn't know the feeling of taking a
place and keeping it
or
securing a village and then
raising the flag and calling it a
victory
no sense of order
or momentum
no front
no rear
no trenches laid out in neat parallels
no patent rushing for the rhine no beach
heads to storm and win and hold for the
duration
they didn't have targets
they didn't have
a cause
they didn't know if there was a war of
ideology or economics or hegemony
or spite
on a given day they didn't even know
where they were
they didn't know the terms of war
it's architecture the rules of fair play
when they took prisoners which was rare
they didn't know how to question or to
ask or whether to release a suspect or
to beat on him
they didn't know how to feel
whether seeing a dead vietnamese to be
happy
or sad
or relieved
and whether
in times of quiet to be apprehensive
or content
whether to engage the enemy
or elude him
they didn't know how to feel when they
saw villages burning revenge
loss
peace of mind
or anguish
they didn't know
all these uncertainties never
articulated in war stories
emotion
squandered on ignorance
they did not know good
from evil